yo what's going on michael king aka king
riches and we're here to rape people and
tell them if they're peng or they're
buttons straight up yeah so obviously
i'm one of the judges here i'm gonna be
the best judge the most savage one the
other two it's gonna go good i think the
other judges are kind of soft i don't
think they're gonna like tell them how
it is but i keep it real you know you
know what we're in stratford eight maybe
if we're in central probably nine here
eight you know the the pretty they're
pretty [ __ ] go to where the money is
they're just gonna be acting nice you
know telling them what they want to hear
and i'm not yeah i'm here to tell the
truth trust me so watch out for me in it
yeah listen to what i say because that's
what it really is all right guys just
putting it out there everyone's
beautiful inside and outside but today
strictly judgment you know for the
people if you're full doesn't matter
your personality you might be at times
10 and that's all right someone out
there is gonna love you okay lovely
peace out we out so so today we're
rating people one to ten one to ten he's
how tall are you look at like i'm into
the tall guys you know yeah i'm gonna
give them eight
okay give me a little twelve darling
twelve three sixty
all right all right all right i'm gonna
give you
six and a half what did you say how tall
are you
first of all what are those
yeah primark t-shirt
uniqlo unicode
this is prime minister i i get a number
get a number but anyway what am i saying
what am i saying do you go gym do you go
gym though no i know
blood get in the gym but i would say
because you're six free i'd say probably
and obviously i'm a guy so i'm not
really trying to rate you like that bro
like you get me don't get excited bro
but i'd say what's it probably a
6.5 and you know that's seven do you
know seven is average eight is
supermodel she thinks you're a
supermodel because you're no no no no no
five is like an average bro five is
average
i feel like i'm above average
however i think your personality is 11.
yeah
and you know what as well you wasn't
scared you weren't scared and
no it's everything
the whole package did you get it but we
appreciate you thank you appreciate you
thank you for stopping i just he said
six three i'm sorry i gotta when i hear
six three that's all i see that's all i
see yeah i like it i like it
listen i'm gonna like i was a bit like
you know he was nice to look at when he
put on the glasses he gave clark kept
vibes yeah but the shoes were really
spinning yeah no the shoes were matched
you know you don't even say nothing
about shoes or two i know it's not you
know you've not got mesmerized three or
more no i said six and a half oh my god
if you had better shoes
um your your hair stunning your have
very nice face very symmetrical i feel
like you could model actually also good
looking i like the beard i like the
beard i'm not a fan of the sandals and
the socks i think you could have did
yeah i mean what i mean who said today
honestly i just came out for work man
i'm telling you tired of the excuses
you fell i'm just lazy yeah i'll just
laser can we probably just say next time
um i'm not that's wrong
i'm personally i'm not a big tattoo
person
yeah i
this is just my rating
um i feel like those could be wider you
know they're a little well
i'm gonna give you an eight i'm gonna
give you a seven you know what the
hair's bouncing the eyebrows not you
the eyebrows are eyebrowing the lipstick
is lipsticking faces symmetrical you're
giving them what's a like jasmine you're
giving jasmine vibes beautiful
slender give us a little tour
come on babe you should not shake it
shake your hair shake it all right you
see
giving the model vibes you know i mean
you could be on a poster so i'm here for
it i'm giving you a nine i think you're
beautiful you're stunning you cute man
i'm here for the tats i'm here for the
tabs i like a hairy guy shows that you
know it's a man the sliders are sending
me those sliders and socks that means
your toes are dead but if they if no if
they're not release it but i'm not gonna
let you do that you get it but nice face
the beard is connecting the braids
making you look older than you are
because i know you're not that old you
look about 22. here's the nice smile
yeah let me see nice smile it's not
veneers we're here for it we're here for
it
howdy
wow
oh my gosh that scared me so the hair's
hair and it's a bit greasy but we can
deal with that it's hot it's hot it's
hot so so i'm going to give you a
6.95 she's buffering you though but but
she compliments you but
huh
blood blood
hold on yeah you thought you was
reaching that's definitely a myth yeah
listen mr werewolf here boy like bro
bro
anyway first off first of all yeah
brother they're j's they're children
sliders yeah but bro they are dirty and
they look worked brother you need to
switch them out
get some air maxes or something bro like
you get me bruv your shorts don't know
whether they want to be pattern or
playing brav what is going on with them
shoots bro
no yeah you can after but wait for your
rating brush so your shorts don't know
what they want to do obviously the shirt
standard shirt like it's underneath it's
not for the over by anyway boom hairy
hairy hairy got the attack there let me
see it all right come come come yeah
yeah good looking guy how tall are you
you don't know
you don't know how tall he is
man said send that meters buff
man said centimeters brav
we have better deception in here but
anyway yeah um yeah anyway yeah your
girlfriend very cute nice slender shape
nice the shoes yeah a little bit groggy
a little bit groggy yeah but yeah yeah
come come come come come nice hair nice
face all of that boom boom boom all
right you know what you're cute couple
you work yeah but she's obviously better
looking than you and i'm a guy because
i'm not trying to date you bro yeah so
boom anyway yeah i'd say right now right
here i reckon could do better but imma
say five yes i'll give him a five it's
my rating it's my rating
he's got a hundred you're not i don't
care
no one could hear you bad cause you he
got a hotter girl than you well let's
not get into that
anyway yeah are you siblings or are you
joking oh all right all right yeah that
would be weird yeah that yeah we don't
want to advocate that here anyway so
boom like you now i'd say
i'd give you honestly but i'm just mean
in it i'll give you a 7.5 i'll give you
a 7.5 you're not saying yeah yeah i
definitely hired in him come on man
mr werewolf man what what rate you guys
oh so basically i was going to say if i
actually try my ratings will go over 10
did you get because i wasn't even trying
i still got above five so that says a
lot thank you very much i wasn't trying
to by the way oh yeah
to be honest with you i feel a bit
violated
did you have gave me a high score
chad gave me a high score i feel like um
they were being you know a bit a bit
biased beating the girls always up high
happiness with the time in our society
nowadays i always find i enjoyed it yeah
now i'm gonna have to change my jesus i
thought that this was nothing but facts
i'm better looking than him and yeah
yeah don't listen to her
um
she talks too much
she needs to learn how to church for a
bit but it happens a lot all right guys
one to ten all right first of all first
of all a question how tall are you
i'm very sure
uh i like the shoes okay i think what do
you guys
i like especially those
um i think the tie-dye could use some
work it's just like that's giving me
hawaii yeah yeah yeah
i'd have to say
four because i'm very tall
i don't have to say for you
also for it's called oh it's not
finished it's not finishing
all right so obviously you are babies to
me this is giving mexico on the beach
with your girlfriend but the trainers
are cold you kept it safe you kept it
safe kept it dark so i'm not gonna lie
i'm gonna give you both basically look
yeah you know what the drip is the same
for the trainers four and a half you
kept it too safe four calm nearly made
it halfway all right you know i'm gonna
keep it real with you man in it yeah
like not everything they're saying about
the shoes sticking it you smashed it
you're not on holiday breath you're in
stratfor shopping center bruh he's not
he's after him he's on halftime yeah
yeah yeah but he's not bad six weeks
yeah but we're in london bro don't worry
about it yeah boom i see the little
change and that obviously come on
i see the bubbling breath come on man
yes i see the bubbling don't worry about
it bro yeah i like you got the j's on
and that calm come come do you know what
i'd probably say four's in it but you
can improve
listen learn from this brav you don't
say you can improve man but anyway you
lot are doing good man safe obviously it
was rated r 10. yeah we both got fours
by all of them
[Music]
i kind of rushed out the house this
morning so cause this guy was rushing me
tell you one thing yeah
when the girls are rating you've got to
remember these are older girls who like
older men in it so they're rating you on
those spaces of if they were to like
think about dating you like they
wouldn't do it because you're below
what they want in ratings
remember like a lot of the things they
were talking about were your clothing in
it and they're probably looking for
someone that's a bit older hence why
you got that kind of a rating so
more time you're good why aren't your
shoes tied come on it's it's the culture
like you have to have your you have to
have your shoes unleashed i'm a big
safety person
and i thought you were too based on like
the the shirt and what i'm seeing is
you're not true to what you believe just
because my shoes
it's just reckless to me are they
touching the floor because i can't trip
over you got me there you got me there
i like i like the hair okay but i
but i think
like the trainers i'm not really big on
safety so that's fine to me um i like
the combats give me a little 12. we'll
talk about all right all right
you're wearing work t-shirts i'll allow
you anti-knife crime all for that for
the people love that let me see that is
that a wet pouch or your pouch
okay i like did you see your nails
okay
oh mad mad all right the hair i'm loving
the hair you're giving it natural
no she didn't show me the nose because
they're not done
i was like no they're done they're like
raptor claws
wait why do you want to show them that's
a good one
oh that's why that's what i wanted to
see all right i would give you
a
five but you need to come back and
change your top so you can see the whole
outfit
and also the lashes we need a refill
baby reefer but it's good you're still
at five you're still a five baby girl
still a five these lot are just capping
in it they're just being horrible broth
like yeah i think yeah honestly
obviously you're young for me in it like
but what i'm saying to you i think the
shoes
yeah who cares blood yeah the combat who
cares who cares look i'm looking at the
face and the hair yeah and the and the
size i think you're at least
6.5 maybe even a seven depending on how
you're dressed you know what i'm saying
they're just capping don't even listen
to them they're just saying anything i
told you i'm the truth yeah these are
two kids
i just can't look at she doesn't have
her shoes tied i just that doesn't
nothing
happens
i'm from the suburbs we've hired our
shoes she's from the suburbs yeah we
talked about this ain't no sun
me personally if i wasn't working
it would have been a whole different
story i'd even do my hair this morning i
woke up like this is where it is i just
said they said let's rape i said okay
you see with me i don't care what the
ratings are because me i know i'm a 10
on another day so it is what it is
okay so we're rating people one to ten
that's the panel all right let me start
alright boom okay one to ten rov do you
go to the gym
i've been to the gym when when was the
last time two months ago two months ago
brother you need to be in there today
buff today yeah cause that midsection is
talking that's the first thing i look at
yeah and i know i'm being horrible but
i'm trying to help you my bro the swag i
don't know about them air forces man
with the
i don't know i don't care if they're
tired or untied brother i don't like
them bravo yeah and in the shorts yeah i
guess so it goes with the shirt you know
i mean nice shades got the ray bans on i
see you got a nice little wavy haircut
little trim and that got the top button
unbuttoned i see you leaving dangerous
living dangerous bro like you know what
i mean but um all right what would i
give you um obviously i'm a guy i'm not
trying to date you bro like boom i'd
give you probably a five which is
average don't get scared don't don't
stop crying bro is because you need to
get to the gym all right all right so
you get a five yeah that's respectable
that's average how tall are you yeah
okay
so five ten um
okay okay so five ten um
all right so five ten is like average um
um i would say you have a nice space um
i would give you like five six per face
um however you're overweight when you're
overweight you're specifically below
average um so i would give you a four
but you can change it i think if you you
know you got to the gym you could be
solid six i say big bailey's matter yeah
something to lean on but that's the
first thing i saw but i like the the the
the color on thumb i see the tan he's
doing neutrals you don't appreciate
colors he's doing neutrals the tan and
the neutrals yeah yeah it's not yeah
it's good it's meaty but i saw it's
getting there the glasses
yeah
it's giving back your riders but but
we're here for it you know the hair on
the legs is consistent no random wax
marks the beard is the the beard is the
beard is there's no not too many gaps
sunglasses you've been to the
hairdresser's love it i would give you
a 5.5 i said if you got to the gym you'd
be six like this so basically yeah
and most most people are fives but yeah
that's it
i do good i normally get ready to free
so take the fabs here's what it is love
myself anything you take away yeah maybe
don't wear tan shoes hit the gym is what
it is first of all i do like bucket hats
i'm a big fan until i look down and i
saw the sandal i would say facial you
have a nice smile okay um what's your
tattoo up money um that'll minus a point
for me
i would give you a five all right i
think the color of the top is bringing
out your cheekbones brings out the
melanin i love it i love a bucket hat
give me a little 12 turn around you're
looking tired all right the bum's peachy
i like that toes are not bad even though
they're out to be fair and you came from
work so i'll give you a six all right
everything's awesome yeah awesome sauce
but why are your feet out though bro i
hate that man i hate that work what kind
of work
uh in a factory with your feet no no no
what kind of factory is that bro sugar
factory do you step on grapes nah never
so what do you do we make sugar make
sugar ah that's it that's sweet bro but
anyway back to the drip yeah so when
you're back from work but
all i can do is just look brother and i
hate looking at feet that's not neutral
i know it's not drip i know
butt clothes hey work clothes all right
what watch is that let me see that
that's old school bro that's that's you
rubbed off anyway
anyway i'm brother i'm not gonna lie i
didn't want to say nothing yeah but wait
first of all that's what sentiment is
the value of a dollar you know so
this one is good with money brother i
know you're saving peace bro i know you
are
how do you know that i know do you want
to know why because you're wearing
slazzy but i know you're saving peace
because he's wearing slice of jaw
slashing your shoes i've never seen no
one wear that before that's mad that's
how we dress in the characters
you have to climb your tires man you're
in the uk now bro and a bucket huh let
me see what does it say in it gabor's
london i like i like bucket hats i'll
give you that one i'll give you that one
yeah all right if i and trust i'm a guy
i'm not trying to date you maji yeah i'm
just gonna give you a rating yeah
[ __ ]
i reckon you can get girls bruh i reckon
you can get girls
um i'd give you six because obviously
you come from work i understand i
understand respect bro
all right we understand bro we
understand how did you find it
it's good it's good yeah yeah
it's good yeah uh what do you think of
the ratings
yeah the rating is good man yeah worry
i'll get more next time next time yeah
it looks so good
45 minutes a day don't chat rubbish nine
to five plus music monday to sunday
how's that gonna work
there's a space ah what's netflix don't
you what no i don't tv no
i don't instagram
[Music]
so what'd you rap about then would you
do music about if you're boring about
love life
well you've got time for that so you got
time to go gym i don't want to hear no
more we're here here what's your name
tegan k
tbnk so
i don't know you said tbnk right no
oh all right no no no sorry so say that
again slowly so tegan k
tegan k how about
music on and my music is atk today in
see
your
eight days
that way all right talk to me how'd you
feel i went do you know what i'm a bit
upset man's talking about my holes in my
shoes that come on you know what it is
real ones some of your friends won't
tell you that you know what i mean
these people are being real with you so
you can only take it as a positive and
just try and better yourself feel me i
like the shoes i like the shoes you have
a nice smile um i do like the beard um
i'll give you two how did you say two
i hate her
um you know
i'm very tall but the shape up point
your smile your eyebrows are bushing
where they need to bush the beard is
connecting me a little twelve and see if
the bum's peachy the bum's not that
peachy but it's all right it's all right
you come from work so i'm gonna allow
the outfit she's wearing it because
you're not a two you're four and a half
bearing in mind five is average so you
understand don't mind her off to you how
tall are you bro i'm five six five six
five six seven i know you're lying but
anyway boom first of all the shoes
you like them shoes i don't like them
shoes bro them shoes look like you've
been working
like they they look like you've been
working a long day for many days bruh
you know what i'm saying anyway so like
boom all right the jeans yeah standard
primark jeans i don't know 12 pound
jeans i don't know low cost
who knows broth mystery unsolved then
the t-shirt it's lacrosse but who wears
the cost now i don't know in it like i
don't know and that's just going to my
locals though you don't say that mine
are not really dressing up to go to
do you go
oh [ __ ] oh oh oh yeah like yo people at
home yeah mine's not really dressing up
to go to uh
yeah yeah yeah my not really dressing up
to go on and today we're judging books
by their cover it's just like this is
raggeding this is a raggle thing you get
me
and i'm happy and i'm happy and that's
what counts thank you my sister
happiness i love her as well i love her
she's on my side a few people are going
to get a little grilling at the end it's
all right it's all right
it's all right let's go let's go all
right i'm giving i'm giving you honestly
yeah 24.5 you see what i'm saying the
mind the mind gave me a generous a
little judgment i lie i like it that was
generous that's what i'll say bro to
switch things up a little bit what i'm
what i am going to do is i'm going to
actually rate the judges so i got given
twos
threes
fours
fives but monday eight
when months and eight you get me
obviously i'm an 8.5 myself
but i got given low grades tilted right
now i'm going to grade the judges going
from this wave ms you know what i
actually preferred you have all of these
people and you gave me a lot of love and
not even that i know i know i know i
know i know i know but also also you do
look good dark skinned sister um what we
say what we say so a 10 is a beyonce
yeah oh okay i love this i love the
power i love the power i'm going to give
you a good 7.5 i've got a solid solid
7.5 yeah boom so um pearl obviously
everyone knows what she gave me so pearl
how tall are you
one
one one
one just too tall for me that's all yeah
i disqualified women yeah you're like
genuine but i've like visually yeah you
you're good looking but i just
disqualify anyone too tall for man
can we be cool still a bit too tall i
need shorter teeth shorter shorter
shorter there you go there you go
i can work with that um all right cool
the big man over here i did i said a one
a one a one a solid a solid one a solid
one god humbles me god humbles me every
day i love her though i love her though
i love the old love and now it comes to
the guy who looks like constella what's
he what's he called yeah you kind of
look like him a little bit but you got
the muscles and i i give you that reign
of mine you know i don't know about that
but you know what you got the muscle
gang i hear that i go to the gym myself
so you get points for that you got the
chain gang i hear that you get points
for that uh you got the you got the cool
dead's going on oh he's getting blushing
he's blushing he's blushing he's
blushing
um you know what obviously we mind is
different because what you're doing in
life blah blah blah that that's what
really just visually i give you like an
away because you're doing your best
you're doing that you're doing this
you know why because it's michael king
yeah you already know
i don't want to guess you more i don't
want to guess it more but yeah mine
shout out to everyone man all right so
so you have a very nice body you're very
you're very pretty um i like your outfit
all together shoes
like i just feel like here i like the
outfit but like i would put heels with
it so negative one there
um i'll give you six i'll give you six i
could eat
um let's see
i would say
for
with you white toes beautiful we all
love white toes the fluff in the heat
allow you because i've done that when i
hope you look young i'm gonna ask your
age but i've done that legs shaved love
that sleek sleek outfit black keeping it
safe here's curling where it needs to
curl you got the tooth gems i did that
in the 90s but i'm a bit older than you
so it's alright
yeah just what i'm saying the wavy hair
is nice
i'm giving you a seven
right you i love it head to toe i'm
loving the little surfer necklace
thingies whatever they are give me
wherever you give me spin give me spin
but if you give me spin
all right i love it all right she would
wear heels but the thing is we're from
london we wear trainers of everything
so did you get it so i like the ensemble
petite
he's from chicago i don't even know what
they were there for the tennis shoes i
give you seven i give you seven you see
yeah i think the whole ensemble is
giving um wireless vibes i love it i'm
giving you a seven as well let's get our
dirty brother yeah i don't know why you
picked those trainers you should have
put some i don't know some bleach on
those anyway but i think you're pretty
girl you're not saying melanin obviously
come on okay yeah boom i'd give you
a six
yeah you're in good shape yeah yeah yeah
respectable all right you goldilocks
goldilocks yeah all right white toes
yeah yeah yes calm and she noticed that
you got the shaved legs that's good
that's good that's good yeah
um
got the selfridges bag
did you buy something today
what did you buy
i bought a perfume from armani oh yeah
second one of the week
okay say nothing say nothing say nothing
but i know i know better because i know
how us guys think she does
i don't know
so basically i would give you a 6.5
a 6.5 but this is just a normal day if
you if you was if you was out if you was
out out yeah that's what i'm saying if
you was out out it would be higher like
obviously
like like he will definitely move to you
how do you feel about that no that's not
hold on hold on so if my remember you
both will be glammed up in it yeah if
you move to what would be the problem
how tall are you
like
um you two are about the same height for
real i'm actually
fine it's just not working
bro it's just not one of them things
where i'm just not interested and she's
not interested and it's one of them in
it you're both not interested
yeah it was good
yeah it was all right i didn't mind my
ratings you know like
didn't expect it to be high anyways but
i mean the goal on the gray jumpsuit is
pretty that's it yeah definitely i mean
i already got self-confidence i think
i'm a 10.
why are you gassing up these girls
you've been saying this is sim behavior
i guess they're
you give an overweight girl of sex you
give an overweight girl to sex no no no
she's overweight
she's overweight that's below average if
she's overweight that's below average
guys yeah but this is the thing yeah
this is the thing guys yeah that reason
if i if man saw that girl in a club it's
dark like here like the goldilocks and
all that all of that
this is our idea
yeah okay what i'm saying yeah until
until the next day until until the next
day when he sees the blubber i'm just
saying i don't think i will see
[Music]
i'm just saying this is why girls think
they're hotter than they are it's
because of the sims if you're overweight
you're below average if you're
overweight you're below average at the
end of the day yeah
you don't have a sausage so you don't
know what you're talking about yeah
and that's where it stands
to start i hate the plaid i don't know
what you're doing with it
i just
i don't like it i like the shoes i think
those are cute there's no laces which
confuses me um that can
what is it with sprinkles i just say
um yeah yeah um i just feel like safety
first you have a nice space i'll say
like you you've been nice like it's
symmetrical you know black t-shirt i
think matches the shoes i like that
um i like the tracksuit actually i can't
decide if i like the jordans um let's
see how tall are you guys i'm five
eleven
five ten five nine i would give
i give you both sixes actually i like
the slacks uh because this is this one
that's standing out he's wearing all
black so boom a bit a pop of color he's
a footballer so you can't be too big
like him cause i was going to say jim
but he can't read me you see but it's
different different athletes i like the
trainers the shoelaces to londoners we
don't give a heck give me a 12. i like
see i like the green the green on on the
bubbles on the end of his hair nose
piercings cute nice smile you're getting
the eight for me right here i like the
little up ponytail it's giving it's a
bit hot for the tracksuit but i like it
because you're probably not hot yourself
give me a little 12. come here so i see
what you're doing there i see what
you're doing the little band for your
hair pop off let me see the chain all
right i see it it's a cute dream you're
getting six and a half i think you're
both handsome give that to me yeah don't
listen to them listen first of all first
thing i think besides the green yeah the
green pebbles yeah
pajama vibes bruh
i don't this is my right and we don't
care what you like right now yeah listen
pajama vibes yeah come outside looking
like you're ready to go but he looks
like he's ready for sleep bub yeah
anyway besides that i see he's got a
drip he's got the louie he's got the
balenciaga he's even got the crown on
his hand you know what i'm saying king's
in it obviously give me some love bro
safe so yeah boom
yes obviously the hair here obviously
boom yeah yeah yeah i think he could get
girls definitely bruh definitely you got
the two-pack little nose and all that
yeah yeah yeah i would give you honestly
on a real one yeah because you look like
one of my old-school veterans as well
i'd give you
a seven i reckon you could do you could
you could do you could do bits not more
than me though remember that yeah
whatever whatever whatever get in the
gym get in the gym and this one here all
right so you got the j's on yeah they
look a little bit groggy but not not too
bad yeah just a little bit of bleach
toothbrush toothpaste yeah then boom got
the little tech track suit on get me
sleeves rolled up looking like you're
about to do a move mad yeah and he's got
the little footballer like a little
thing yeah yeah yeah i think you could
do bits you're saying a little bit um
you're a bit skinny man get in the gym
man both of you but he's got but listen
you're young you've got time a minute
i'll give you about
five point five point five and the
reason why i say five because the shoes
man
yeah maybe a six i don't know i don't
know it's techie that was condo kinda
like it was it was nice
yeah it was what she didn't know
it's just that nobody gets ready like
that so you say
you just have to firm us it's like no
hard feelings in it
like they they give you a ring it's not
hard feelings that it happens sometimes
you know who's going what do they do
what did they make me because i rate you
in it so obviously come
can't lie i like the chain because where
i'm coming from chinese is very good
from american that yeah i carry you
because you're big because most of my
my dad my brother's all big okay
i'm just kidding because i play football
that's it i heard that
and i don't know why you're in the
summer i don't talk while you're in the
winter vibe i'm bored
you get it
all right yeah your crepes the one on
the right here the front one's kind of
kind of kind of doing something yeah
kind of kind of doing something so the
joggers man i don't care about that
story so what you're wearing it's your
thing you're bolo so you probably if i
see you on road it's a 180
yeah mother's day if i see this if i see
this
it's mad it's bad yeah tattoos got some
meaning to it i don't even i haven't
yeah the earrings calm but their hand is
doing sometimes
i'm saying that every every three weeks
but other than that that's a yeah i'll
i'll give you i'll give you a seven
where red deal which one first anyone
first
nah i don't like you no
i can't lie i don't like you
no no you don't like it i give you six
you give me a six but you mocking me too
much you violated my shoes just because
i think i said i like two shoes these
type of shoes don't need laces he just
had lasers for for having to go
places for extra safety i'm sorry i'm an
official even related he's coming out
okay okay okay save save
i'll give you i'll give you a five but
just because you're not my type i can't
lie you have a
solid five you're less than five that's
a five don't take it less than five i'm
in love with you i can't lie and i'm in
love with you but yeah i'll give you a
10. i can't lie i like the shoes
no no no no no no yeah
yeah she have the shoes i like the shoes
i [ __ ] with the drip or shoes i like i
like the fit and that the smile is nice
as well yeah
you're the type of person i would do
snaps with you every day okay my jeans
are a limited edition you said he didn't
like it what my jeans are my job
yeah i'll give you i'll give you
yeah you like it do you like it so yeah
you're full now
the toenails are not doing it i can't
lie i'm being honest
listen
yeah
but a shoes though denman's day comes
off wish him like
if i go if i go straight i can't find
him
let me see
your dress i'll [ __ ] with it but the
color is just not the cut and it's like
kind of short a little so and i'm kind
of skinning it yeah your hair is calm i
i i don't i don't i don't judge about
hearing [ __ ] your face is calm as well
so i'll probably give you like a what
number like 6.5 ah calm
obviously i'm young so i can't receive
too much
so i'm i don't die from yes but your
thing your thing is
yeah now your jewelry your jewelry the
same as his old gold nice matching yeah
nice you got smooth skin as well so i'll
rate that shoes for summer as well
um you got a nice smile all right i
think in a bucket hat it gives you a
point
but you don't have a bucket hat on no
i'm a tall girl you're about like five
nine i'm not you know you have a nice
smile i'm gonna give you six i'm gonna
give you six that's not gonna give you
six
i'm gonna give you a six except when you
[ __ ] my audio then you're five do you
know what because i know ish i'm gonna
be biased because i love ish i love ish
i'm going to be biased do you know what
the the kicks i love it i'm here for it
you tied your shoelaces for safety i
don't give a heck about that but she
does you didn't give him a point for
tying shoelaces for safety
seven he tied his shoes decided
so me i love ish this is my babes this
is my g so dude and he smile you know i
can't do personality but it's in there
ready look at his eyes he's blinking at
me you get me ish carries the equipment
he makes us look beautiful you guys can
go together you know what the thing is
yeah i'm not gonna sit here and lie i
love two men but one of my exes was mad
short man but you see that you see that
was when i was in church i was my you
know all of that you know the bells
weren't torn from my eyes but it went
the real world didn't it but it's yeah
you see you can't go gym because of what
you do you go gym all right when you add
a bit more we're going to give you half
a point more but i'm not going to like i
like he's waiting see those sweaters
that show the shape of your
you-know-what yeah that's what he's
wearing and that's dangerous the chain
is i like the outfit the watch is cute
he's keeping it basic black you need a
trim though
but i'm gonna give him
aids all right all right my bro uh my
bro i like the shoes the shoes are clean
obviously the drip is calm it's calm
it's cameraman yo listen your own job
your own job bruv i like that brav yeah
all right nice watch calm i'd say i'd
say
i'm a guy i'm going to be horrible to
you five brav i'm gonna be horrible to
you bro but that's my job bruh yeah and
it really i'm being nice so i'll give
you your five in it yeah yeah i've got
that's why i got two months i got this
mic on that mic bro now it's time for
the exit interview where i get to rate
my people them here and i
will be real with you so
king let's start with you first so king
over here
big guy works out
you're clearly improving on himself he's
doing his thing on social media go
follow that um jewelry's calm we like to
see it little bling bling there not in
real simple here with the white tee or
vest trainers doing it so i can't lie no
homo of course gotta give my brother 8.5
he's up there he's doing his thing
come on
this is a good man you know come on he's
a good man come on oh my baby come here
come come come
don't do
that so but we gonna start with the
rating so we see the slides slash
trainers they playing in their own right
matching with the gray has them yo
there's a matching thing going on with
the hair i don't know if you she said
everything on purpose purpose built
come on outfit looking sensational as
she is always yeah i'mma definitely give
you a
i'mma be real
8.5 that's i'm thinking potential wise
makeup i don't even know what you look
like with makeup but you must be
sensational i don't know maybe i could
be wrong it depends if you're doing it
right wow it depends if you're doing it
right all right yeah i'm not going to
comment on what i think of that but i
might you can keep your rating five yeah
we're not trying to blow up egos here
all right paul come my content creator
the people's champion we know you know
her we love her you know how it is i
know how it is i see the outfit is
matching
we're doing well see this
the smile is impeccable her mother's
dress people respect her mother's dress
if i'm gonna put you on the rating scale
and this is what pearl taught me people
i'm being real she told me that eight is
the prettiest girl in a city five is
average
six is above average now if i'm giving
eights already i'm already thinking
certain people are pretty skills in the
city so that i can't keep going
everyone's the prettiest girl in the
city paul is a young successful person i
know her so on a real i'mma give you a
six point five six point five yeah give
myself a five i take this yeah
hey guys i love my job um shout out to
you
i just want to say okay i grew up in the
place with brothers but they'd call me
ugly every day i think i'm a five so
when someone gives me a six i'm excited
stay humble because wonder why if you
stay humble when your expectations are
low they can only be
exceeded all right i want to rate
everybody let's go through that so i'll
give you seven
i'll tell you that i'll tell you that
release eight though i i i have a crush
on you
i think you're so pretty i give you nine
oh my gosh
if i like girls i would fancy her too
he's jealous be accountable
comfortable we just won't be jumping out
of steps
you're right i was going to give you an
8 until you said it and i took it down
because i wanted to humble you
so yeah
so alvi i'll be honest
i didn't i don't i feel like he's like
he knows this you know and i just i
thought it was so slow i didn't want to
give it to him but i'll give it to you
just go and get out girls number just
now no yeah yeah good good job good job
but but i mean let's just be honest
she's the hottest one on the panel
she's the hottest on the head and she's
nice too
most girls as hot as her are like are
boring let me tell you it's because i
used to be your tomboy i'm telling you
that's what makes you nice you do have a
little personality yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
look out for me gonna start podcasting
i'll be here i'll be readily available
on their channels yeah my bad price went
up what's that 10k per view
i love you guys pearly things like
subscribe what's the other one
like subscribe comment
comment like subscribe comment sign up
be a super fan pay will read your
comment pay even if a [ __ ] will read it
as long as it's not offensive basically
michael king aka king riches and i was
here doing the rating with the two young
ladies yeah obviously i was the only one
that kept it real i was the only one
that really was the with the real talk
bro everybody else everybody else every
everybody else yeah they were trying to
be nice so i'm not a nice guy because
they always finish lost don't they they
always finish last don't they yeah
yeah yeah someone broke my heart and now
look at me i went gym and i came back
yeah
but anyway like yeah so yeah i gave the
best rate see he knows as well i gave
the best ratings and that's it in it
like but they they tried they did a
thing but they tried but obviously
let me tell you what it is guys as i
said at the beginning god made everyone
beautifully just that when he was
sprinkling certain things he took his
time with others and rushed but it's not
his fault so you're beautiful plus me
and isha all for the personality do that
mean it's all about the heart these are
savage they're wicked she gave a child a
[ __ ] four or six what is that someone
pushed them out after nine months and
she gave them a four the kid walked off
i'm sorry one person i should give out a
two today
look
i got bullied from a young age i think
we should start him young do you know
what i'm saying you know what i'm sorry
i got bullied too but then at the
smack-ups i want to show that you cannot
trick me at the end of the day realness
is what matters even if you're crusty
build on your personality get your bread
up someone's out there for you someone's
going to love you you know the vibes
look it michael's a stamp
i just started he gasses these girls off
this is the thing we got when guys wanna
when guys want to sleep with you they'll
gas you up like this is just how men are
so he he's a bit of a synth no no i need
you to simp over there please please
simp elsewhere simp that way um
honestly i think i was the best judge
today i feel like i was honest and real
um i i think michael
let him gas up the girls give the guys a
little too low you you were a bit you're
a bit too nice but yeah overall i think
it was a fun day i think i picked a good
panel we could do it again okay guys
thank you so much for watching thank you
guys for being co-host with me today
this was fun
tell the people where they can find you
okay you can find me on youtube michael
king on youtube yeah i'm the one and
only king riches but change the name
rebranding and all that good stuff so
it's michael king on youtube yeah make
sure you follow that um instagram
ambitions of power tick tock king rich's
all one word yeah boom make sure you
follow and big up to hurley look just
pearly things channel yeah make sure
you're leaving comments and likes yeah
make sure hi i'm ems you can't find me
anywhere because all my socials are
private but starting a podcast soon so
delfina m's for when we start thank you
just pearly things like comment
subscribe become a super fan look out
for the live shows they're lit ish is
the best you know i mean
look out for michael if you want to get
big if you want to lose weight pt over
there don't be overweight guys come on
we love you okay guys don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification bell the way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos while
you're at it our clips channel is in the
description so go subscribe to that and
i will talk to you next time
as many of you know i was just banned on
tick-tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform
if you want to help please consider
sending a super thanks below every
donation helps and it helps make what we
do possible